good afternoon everyone i am sad
omer i'm the director of the yale
institute for global health and i'm
delighted to welcome you uh to the ygh
global health conversation series uh
our latest event in this series um
we in addition to ygh we are indebted to
the
george herbert walker junior lecture
series um
that is supported by
the macmillan center uh today i'm
pleased to be joined by my co-moderator
dr linda arnold um she's an associate
professor of pediatrics
and emergency medicine at yale school of
medicine
um she's a former peace corps volunteer
and she has
been actively engaged in global health
and education in fact i you know
the first time i met her we were both in
panama and
um and her effort and she was doing work
on capacity building
um and in addition to that she has
worked on program development for
more than 30 years she's also the
north american representative to the
standing committee of the international
pediatric association
welcome linda it's great to have you
with us today and as a reminder
all attendees have their volumes and
video features muted but of course we
are eager to incorporate
your questions uh you can simply submit
those questions
using the question and answer feature uh
we are also
recording today's session and it will be
available on youtube
and the ygh facebook page
um and now let me introduce uh everyone
to today's distinguished guest uh
um henrietta iv who's the
seventh executive director of unicef
which the position she began in january
2018.
um she is not new to global health and
development
uh and she's been a real champion of
economic development
education health and humanitarian
assistance
as well as the disaster relief uh in a
public service as well as
uh private sector and non-uh profit uh
leadership career
um that spans more than four decades
uh one of uh her career highlights is
that she was the
uh between 2007 and 2009 she was
the executive director she was the
administrator of the usaid
um and she was the first woman
to serve in these uh in this role and
was responsible
for managing approximately 40 billion
dollars
of u.s foreign assistance annually
including support to peoples and
countries uh recovering from
disasters building their futures
economically
politically and and socially before her
career
at usaid uh she was appointed assistant
administrator for
asia and assistant administrator for
private enterprise in the same agency
she serves uh on the boards of overseas
private investment corporation
and the millennium challenge corporation
and in
2009 um executive director four
received the distinguished service award
the highest
award the secretary of state can bestow
so um without further ado you know i
want to welcome executive director for
and um you know look forward to talking
about
um about some of the issues
uh that we'll be focusing on um
and in terms of um the the way it will
go
um uh we would uh appreciate
uh we'll start with uh director four's
remarks
uh brief remarks uh and and then we'll
have
a question answer session which um
dr arnold and i will moderate and
we'll also take audience questions
well thank you very much uh sad i really
appreciate it and
i will start formally and then let's get
into a good conversation
so thank you very much and also thank
you very much to the yale institute for
global health
for welcoming me here today we have a
number of programs that we do together
which are all
exciting and they lead to in many paths
of the future
so they lead to many areas that we're
going to be talking about and so
i appreciate it we appreciate it at
unicef very much
i am looking forward to discussing with
all of you
uh what is truly an emergency
of our time and it is covet 19.
what we need to do as a global community
to support children's health and
well-being through
and importantly beyond this
extraordinary time
and i say a global community very
deliberately
building and strengthening systems for
the future cannot be done alone by
governments or
agencies like unicef it requires the
ideas
and the innovations the funding the
collaboration
of an ecosystem of partners all working
together
collaboration has certainly been a
hallmark of the yale unicef partnership
across collaborative ties between us
are strong and also they are growing
unicef has benefited from yale's
leadership in global health fellowship
with two yale students who've been
working in our health section
this past summer nicholas alipui
yale's lecturer at the jackson institute
for global affairs was a long time
senior leader at unicef and he is now
bringing his expertise to the capstone
course on non-communicable diseases
at yale and every year unicef welcomes
yale's experts in a diverse number of
areas
from child nutrition and feeding to
early childhood development to hiv aids
and of critical importance today the
vaccine demand laboratory
which saad is leading with one of
unicef's senior social
scientists but i hope that we can
continue to do even more together
in the years ahead in fact the diversity
of thinking around
the many areas of children's health and
well-being
is part of what i would like to leave
with you today
we cannot support children's health if
we fail to support
all of the other ingredients that
support their development and well-being
education protection from violence and
abuse
water and sanitation mental health
nutrition social protections skills
development
so they can prepare for the world of
work all of these ingredients help
support
optimal health and development and all
the systems that support these
ingredients
came under attack with covet 19
the unprecedented measures that we have
taken to contain the virus
schools were closed leaving 1.6 billion
children out of school immunization
campaigns around the world ground to a
halt
parents stopped taking their children to
medical centers because they were afraid
of coming into contact with the virus
households were hit hard by the economic
impact
families are finding it difficult to
make ends meet for even the most
important and basic necessities like
food
and children and women have become more
exposed to violence and abuse
online but also within their own
households
but what about those places where these
systems were already
weak or even non-existent places where
primary health care
is a day's journey or more from where
people
live where crowded conditions make it
impossible to self-distance where a
family of seven or even
ten share a single room where
humanitarian emergencies
like conflicts make reaching children
with basic services like vaccinations or
treatment for severe acute malnutrition
extraordinarily difficult
we're one of the best defenses against
19
hand washing is simply out of reach
because of lack of clean water
and a bar of soap covid19 has reminded
us all of the
stark inequalities around the world
between the haves
and the have-nots and in the most
extreme cases
places of conflict or drought for
example
in yemen or in the sahel or for refugees
living in overcrowded camps and the
pandemic
is making that situation even worse
in many ways unicef was made for this
kind of an emergency
with offices in over 190 countries
our staff members are working shoulder
to shoulder with governments
to deliver nutrition to vaccinate
children
provide water emergency health care
education and protection services to the
displaced
our staff members and partners are also
working to give
development a foothold in parts of the
world where
a vaccination a bed net a drink of clean
water
a cup of nutritious food a seat and
classroom
or a paved road can seem like a distant
dream
and we're directly supporting the covet
19 response on a number of fronts
we're delivering life-saving supplies
we're working with communities to
provide
information and messaging to prevent
infection
we're providing online and distance
learning
to millions of out of school children
we're keeping vaccination campaigns
up and running we're providing water
sanitation and hygiene
supplies to communities that are
battling covet 19
we're playing the lead role in the act
accelerator initiative and the kovacs
facility
to ensure that any vaccine is delivered
fairly and
equitably around the world and
throughout
we're working shoulder to shoulder with
governments as they rebuild stronger
schools
hospitals resilient water and sanitation
services
for the future and we're helping them to
strengthen lasting community-based
health systems
where all the services that children and
their families need
from vaccinations to nutrition to
obstetric care
can be found in one place because
supporting children's health and
well-being
depends on supporting the whole child
their health but also their development
their education
and their access to services today i
look forward to discussing how unicef is
working with our partners around the
world
public and private alike to meet these
needs and to use this moment
as a chance to reimagine the systems the
children
are counting on but we'd also like to
hear from you
i'm sure that many of you will answer
the call to public
and global service in the health field
and beyond
perhaps you'll go to work in agencies
and organizations dedicated to the
education and economic empowerment of
young people
or become development professionals
diplomats
policy professionals ngo or civil
society workers
innovators business people and teachers
so please let us know your thoughts
contribute any research or ideas you
might have
on solutions or technologies that might
better serve children and young people
consider doing a report on the issues
affecting their lives
and futures and send us your ideas on
innovations we need you on this journey
with us
through your work you can make a
difference in the world
you can build brighter futures for a
generation of children
so once again thank you very much and
back to you assad and linda
thanks um so i'll start with the
questions um
the um obviously
there has been a lot of disruption of
routine services as you mentioned
um and uh including immunization
services and
unifor unicef along with
its in-country partners often forms the
backbone
of the technical capacity that various
countries have
what is your assessment of the current
situation has do you think there has
been a bounce back
in immunization services do you think i
know that you issued a call
uh for resumption of these services uh
lately so
if in terms of your expectations whether
the system
will is likely to bounce back soon
so the honest answer is we don't know
yet
what has happened is that primary health
care services
are down so routine immunizations
those routine immunizations that you get
when you are
less than one year old or less than five
years old
are way down in some of our countries
they are down 40 to 60 percent
some of that is due to supplies being
interrupted uh it has been difficult to
find
air freight cargo space it has been
difficult sometimes to cross the
airspace sometimes to
cross into the country to allow for
delivery
at other times it is because a family is
worried
that if they go to a primary health
clinic that they will get
covered 19 or another disease and they
are just
worried so routine immunizations
are down and as you know they have to be
in a pattern
and we are very worried that families
are not coming back in the same numbers
that they should be coming back
and we're worried about measles we're
worried about polio
then we also have campaigns and
campaigns really
such as the polio campaign they become
a big push and it is backed by the
government
they want to uh make sure that they
vaccinate 100
of the children or as close as we can
get to it and we go
by field area within a country
these campaigns are more likely to be
coming back quickly and sad i can tell
you that they
are coming back so the the specialty
campaigns are starting to come back into
the system again
but we have one other real problem which
is that there is a lot on social media
that are um negative
commentaries about getting a vaccination
that
if you do vaccinate that your children
will get whatever that disease is
that you're being vaccinated from we
have got to be able to counter the
misinformation
that is um often too ubiquitous
on the internet and in social media
platforms
that that say that you should worry that
you should have vaccine hesitancy
we need to be able to convince people
that vaccines work
they do work we know they work but we
need families to believe it
and to come in and to get their children
vaccinated
it's also going to be true for adults in
copen 19 so assad
any ideas that you and
the school have on ways that we can talk
about
getting vaccinations this would be very
important
yeah well thank you and in fact as you
alluded to we
are starting and have started a
partnership with unicef
on specifically on addressing
misinformation and in certain cases
unfortunately disinformation
but using evidence-based approaches to
do so
um because you know just like we need to
bring
um the best science to vaccine
development we need to
bring the best set of evidence from
social sciences and other
and quantitative sciences and other
sciences to
to addressing misinformation and
disinformation i'll
give the next question to linda
many of us are concerned that during the
pandemic there has been a disparate
effect
of covid related restrictions and
systems and services disruptions
on children who are living in poverty
and members of other at-risk or
marginalized populations
and we've all heard reports of increased
food insecurity domestic violence
sexual abuse child marriage and child
labor
what kinds of things are you seeing in
the field
well i wish you i could tell you that we
were not seeing any of those things but
we are we're seeing all of them
so one of the things that happens in
covet 19
is that resources and services are
rearranged every
and what it means is that some of your
health care workers who had been
working on another area are now
redirected
to uh working on covets so
uh part of what we are very worried
about are the
non-communicable diseases and you
mentioned things like
child marriage and you mentioned
some areas that we often don't speak
about which is the mental health
problems
these all need counseling and they need
psychosocial support
so that when our workforces
out around the world are diverted into
something else because
these are usually very thin capacities
but when they are now battling covet 19
then
the support in other areas drops off so
the needs are great
it is true in almost every country we
worry the most
to your very good point about the
poorest
countries we worry about the poorest
populations
in the poorest countries and we
particularly worried about the girls
so girls become liable for early child
marriage
it is often because their parents wish
to keep them
safe and they believe that when they
reach puberty that to keep them safe
means that they should marry them
they do not have the economic
wherewithal to
keep them and that they worry that going
to school will not be helpful
so child marriage looms very large for
girls on many continents we also worry
about just household work girls being
kept
out of secondary school you know the
numbers
primary school almost all
children have a chance to go to primary
school but then the numbers drop
way off for secondary school and for
girls it usually is
staying in the household look after
older family members or child marriage
for boys it is usually um that they are
getting lured into some form of a
service to a militia
or that they are asked to make a living
out on the streets
to earn money for their family and with
the economic
crisis that has come with cove at 19 if
your
father or mother are without work
you go out to work as a young man or as
a young woman
and we are very worried that they will
never return to school and that's what
we saw
during the ebola crisis is that at least
half of the girls did not report return
to school
so it's important we need to be thinking
about
the children that are most vulnerable
and we need to think about the
reallocation of resources within a
country
so that you can invest in children and
young people i know that you talked
a bit earlier about challenges and
difficulties in getting food and
nutrition to children in
sort of far-off places or really
anywhere during the pandemic
have there been strategies that have
been successful or
kind of so one of the things we dream
about
is to really look at systems so
food systems operate from a rural farm
to an urban center and you know the
numbers
urbanization is moving along at a very
fast
pace and what it means is the diets
change
there is a different diet when you are
living on your own
farm than there is when you go into an
urban center
but food systems need to follow the
population
and they need to provide a diverse diet
we believe that at least one out of
every three
children are not getting the nutrition
that they need
two are not two out of three are not
getting a diverse diet
so what does that mean either that it's
not affordable
or that it's not accessible or that
their parents or they
do not know what would comprise a
nutritious
diet but it has long lasting effects
so if a child is not properly nourished
in that first three years of life that
first thousand days
it just means that their bones do not
grow
as strong that their brains do not
grow as well connected as children
who've had a better chance at nutrition
and if we are to ever catch stunting
or wasting and stuff them in their
tracks we're going to have to get these
food
systems to work so food systems
are extremely important and linda
there's one other
very sobering statistic young people
don't want to be farmers anymore
they see their their parents just
struggling to make it on a farm
and they leave the farms they go to the
cities where there's digital
connectivity
they're adolescents and it's very hard
so
we're going to need lots of farmers
they're going to have to be digitally
connected
but young people are going to have to
want to be farmers or the food systems
cannot work well and during covet 19
we've seen
many border closures so food systems
were stopped
often but we need governments to help us
we need businesses to help us
we need schools to help us to train but
we need above
all good food systems and the
realization
that nutrition is important not just for
small
children but also for adolescent mothers
for everyone in
every stage of life
great um so um there is um
you know in this outbreak um
it has been an all hands on deck
situation
and where everyone has to come together
at the country level
at the global level and unicef has
provided some of the most useful
uh pair of hands uh in in this global
effort
but the reality is that this outbreak is
not
just impacting children it's impacting
adults
particularly but not exclusively the
elderly
and unicef's stated mission focuses on
children
um and so how do you sort of resolve
that
um not tensioned you know that's that
alignment or how do you deal with that
alignment in terms of unicef's
child-focused mission but having skills
and resources
and capacity specifically at the country
level
that is so useful and essential for a
pandemic response
that goes beyond children
um well so sad we try to be available
for everyone and our expertise and our
knowledge and our
uh country presence which is indeed
um a real asset at this moment in time
so
what happens when covert 19 hits
the government often talks about what
they should be doing
with their budgets and what should they
invest in
and we try to make the case and i hope
we're making it well
that an investment in children is the
best investment you can make they are
the
ultimate investment as they often say we
are 25
of the world but we're 100 of your
future
so we try to convince governments that
they need to make
an investment in education and health
systems primarily but
for children the second is that the
expertise that we carry often
follows in a child's life so
for instance mental health is something
that
we have not talked about in our age
group
because we were afraid to do so you
didn't tell your family you
certainly didn't tell your boss at work
or you might lose your job
but this generation of young people
they want to talk about it we have to
make it okay
so what unicef can do in a country is
talk about mental health
and how important it is i mean most
mental health problems start by the age
of 14
so if we do not catch it early in
childhood
it means that there will be
repercussions in the decades to come
in the adult population at the lockdown
and the restrictions in movement have
created
a lot of violence physical and sexual
at home it has also created
a new dynamic in many households
because one or another of the
breadwinners
has lost their economic income it
creates
tension and violence in a way that we
have
we have not seen so helplines
uh parenting forms are all extremely
important
so you might think that that was just
because unicef new children
but it's because children live in
families and we look after the families
and for unicef it will be important to
look after mental health
to keep families together it will be
important to look after
water and water system to try to keep
communities safe
and clean hygienic it will be important
to look after distance learning
because children need to be in school
it's their futures
and we've got to focus on immunization
because children can lose their lives to
measles or another disease rather than
to covet
and then to linda's earlier point we
must be able to make sure that there's
enough nutrition and food
so the children can move beyond this
cove in time
and still have healthy strong bodies
i thank you for even
alluding to just the numerous needs that
children have and how
those early and foundational childhood
experiences
and health status can sort of have
lifelong effects
one of the things that we as
pediatricians always stress is the
importance of play
towards normal development and at a time
when everyone is
incredibly stressed out when you know
there's a lot of tension around children
are out of school
taking on other roles what can be done
at the country level and globally
to promote the importance of just
regular childhood play
and and routine physical activity in
terms of children's well-being and
normal childhood development
thank you linda well we do believe in
play and i hope you're going to allow
some of these students that are still um
around the yale center
time to play also because we never grow
out of it
um but during the height of the pandemic
when there were
many lockdown restrictions that you must
stay in your apartments and this is in
many of the highly developed cities in
europe or in north america
uh it was very hard on children because
they they
they want to go play and you can't
necessarily play
in the apartment that you're living in
and there all of a sudden the apartment
seemed very small and very crowded
and you didn't have any friends there
and so it's very
hard on a child so we were encouraging
that there be times every day when
children could go out and play
and they could go out and play just
right around their apartment building
or that there might be a nearby park
that they could go to safely
at a distance and they could go play but
it's very important it's part of the
makeup
of um uh childhood and
of a healthy uh
young adult so it's it's a very
important issue we've been speaking up
about it
but we can use the help of every
pediatrician
who can who can prescribe it to families
and to um governments alike
very nice so we have a question from our
students compiled by one of our faculty
members who
teaches our global health course and
so a number of our public health
students and others
are passionate about working in
humanitarian sector what are the skills
especially skills of the future um that
you think
they should acquire for them to be able
to serve
more effectively in the humanitarian
sector
both in health and otherwise as well
so be a problem solver i don't think we
can teach you everything
in school and we can't teach you
everything with books
but you will learn the context you're in
the beauty of the world around us is
that we
have thousands upon thousands of
cultures
and they will all react differently so
there will be different ways that you
can affect them
and when you get out into the field with
an agency like unicef
you will see the environment and the
ecosystem that we are working in
building trust with your community is
one of the most important things that
anyone working in health can do
or education but in health particularly
we saw it in the democratic republic of
congo
when ebola first came in if a
community health worker spoke the local
dialects and was
of the community and was considered an
important member of a community
they were listened to people paid
attention
what you should not eat in the way of
bush meat what you
should not do in the way of preparing
bodies
for burial people listen to them so
having that
trust is important and to have that
trust you need to listen very closely
to the communities that we are serving
that you
will be serving so um i
think that's probably the single most
important uh quality um maybe you could
call it empathy
maybe maybe you could call it good
listening but you need to
feel what the people you're serving are
feeling
and to see life through their eyes and
if you can
you can help them the other thing that i
that i can see in our world is
it is going to be essential that we move
on primary health care
and that we move in digital health so
understanding digital health and what
its capacities can be
in high-tech low-tech
no-tech environments will be very
important i mean right now
we move vaccines to little refrigerators
out in the rural communities that have
one little solar panel that keeps them
running
uh day and night uh that is one kind
of a low-tech solution that we
that's affordable that we can put
everywhere in the world
and you need to know all of those
kinds of solutions because digital
health is coming
artificial intelligence is coming also
so that you can
remotely diagnose you can do it over a
cell phone
but we don't have it in every place and
we are trying to
connect the other half of the world to
the internet
we're trying to connect every school in
the world to the internet
in the next five years if we can do it
and if we could then it means every
community would be connected and every
uh primary health clinic so those would
be good skills to learn
in addition to that very important um
but difficult one that's empathy of just
listening and feeling
that you're with your community
linda
sorry you're unmute
okay i knew that um maybe we'll do one
more
one more of the questions from the q a
um
someone has asked about concerns in
working with adolescents on sexual and
reproductive health
about how can we reassure both
adolescents and their parents that it's
safe to return to services and care and
if there are any insights to be gained
from previous emergencies like ebola
and i think that also ties into what
we've talked about increased domestic
violence child marriage you know and
access to just reproductive health
services in general
so um in the news today
was one of those wonderful stories about
a hospital in which
a number of mothers had come because
they would accept
mothers who tested positive in covid and
they were coming there to deliver
their babies and this hospital accepted
them
so they were getting a good experience
on how to deliver
healthy babies uh that are not testing
positive uncovered
from uh positively
tested coveted mothers
so an experience from one hospital like
that
is a very important experience and it's
one that we need
to pass along to a number of other
countries
and villages and towns and cities
because
everyone needs that prenatal
care and you need the care before during
and after the birth of a child so
obstetric care
is way down i mean i wish the people
were coming into the primary
health clinics and into the community
centers
but they're staying home so that then
means that
midwives who are out in the in the
villages
are exceedingly important and it means
that they need
water and soap so that they can try to
keep
everything as hygienic as possible
the second example is from hiv aids
so there are many young people
particularly adolescents
who want to test themselves for hiv aids
they also want to test themselves for
covid
they want to be self-empowered and so
they want a self-test
kit and we're not very good as a world
in developing self-tests we tend to
develop tests that
a doctor gives to us or a nurse gives to
us and
then that's enough but young people
want that and they want to tell each
other
about how to keep themselves safe so
one of the areas we've been encouraging
is the young people
talking to other young people there are
young people
who have decided to open up hiv aids
clinics and they're operating them
they're all 17 18 19 20 21
22 years old and they're operating
clinics it's not an adult's
clinic it's for adolescents uh for
adolescents buy adolescents and they
they really believe in it and young
people tend to flock to those places
because they
trust their age mates um
sometimes more than they trust us so
i think there are lots of ways to get
health advice
health prevention health treatment out
to adolescents and at least some of the
lesser serviced areas
in ways that we just have not thought of
in the past
but the world is changing and i think we
can come out of this
stronger and smarter about how we can
reach
more of the millions of people in need
no that's that's great and and i think
that's a very useful perspective
we have a question um an interesting
question in the sense that
you know um it's about you and
resolution one three two five and for
uh the audience who's not familiar with
this this is a resolution that
reaffirms uh the role women have
uh in conflict resolution and there is
proportionate impact they suffer
from conflicts and you know similar
stuff
and it says that you know un agencies
should include women
um in um security responses
the question is pandemics are the
global health security um
you know catastrophe or uh um issue
uh that we are facing any thoughts on
inc you know human resolution one three
two five
and uh the pandemic
well it's um it's it's
right on the mark women can be uh
massively helpful in peace negotiations
so we are trying to think through as the
united nations
how to link humanitarian development
and peace together as you
all well know uh the women are on the
front line
of being health care workers it is
predominantly women and part of the
difficulty for women is that when the
schools are closed
and they need to be home with children
that their
job is that of working in a hospital or
working in a school
and that's where they need to be and
they it's hard for them to also be at
home
so women are really being pulled in many
directions at this point in time but if
we are
all sensitive to this and give a chance
for
more uh home health care flexible work
hours
ways that women we can make it easier on
women
they are a powerful force in the
most recent negotiations for yemen
there is a group of women who have been
activated to be part of the peace
negotiations we are also seeing that now
in some of the countries in the sahel
we've been seeing it in a number of
places around the world but this is a
force
that is just beginning it's very
promising we all have to get right
behind
it and try to encourage it and we need
to be
thoughtful about the lives of women
that we are giving them enough time and
space that they can look after their
their
um responsibilities at home as well as
their
responsibilities in their profession
very nice linda do you want to go next
sure um this is more of a kind of a
broader question but i think it pulls
together a lot of the different things
that we've been talking about
but what what are the recent covid
related setbacks and
really major barriers now to achieving
the sustainable development goals
related to child health
in particular
well gosh it's hard to know where to
start on that
i mean we're we're very worried that
we've gone back um
30 years i mean as a world we have
really done well on a lot of the
indicators for children like child
survival and stunting and
wasting but now we are we're very
worried we
we just do not know if we can
um hold the gains
and in fact it looks like we cannot hold
the gains so
what do we do about that um in my mind
it is that we need to be
innovative there are so many innovations
that our world dreams of and puts into
effect i mean when you walk through a
refugee camp
you will see some very creative ways to
filter water and they're
using um often a mask or a little bit of
their
tent and they're creating a fiber
filter for the water faucet that's just
not far outside their door
but we need to look at frugal
innovations and very sophisticated
innovations and put them to work
so that we can take advantage of
the new world that exists and reach more
people
more effectively which is why i've
mentioned digital health
it's it's coming it just hasn't come yet
ubiquitously to our developing world but
it's coming
so aren't there some innovations that
you have seen somewhere in some part of
the world
that we could be putting to use that
mean that we can
leapfrog the technologies and you know i
grew up in the
in the era when you had a telephone that
was wired
into the wall at home and it
was attached you didn't move but then
cell phones came and i mean you never
look back
we need all of those in the health
sector
and in the education sector one of the
things that
this generation is telling us is that
they care about digital technology
they want to use it they're empowered
and they
are going to put it to use so therefore
or that we can create an internet of
good things
that we can teach them and share
knowledge
we've just launched a global development
commons that
some students have been helping us with
from yale and a number of other
institutions so that you can get answers
that you've been wanting to get
on a global development commons and this
will
all be in our internet world but
it's it's an exciting time
for what we can change in the world and
one will be
distance learning i mean there is no
reason
why we cannot have remote learning
distance learning in
every country in the world uh whether
it's by
radio television sms tablets
internet we could do this as a world
this is one of those
once-in-a-generation opportunities
and if we can do that for education we
can do that in health
so um the next question is
one of our teen participants so so we
have a few
non-yale attendees and and this comes
from a person who
has a very uh sort of um interesting and
inspiring
organization that she has set up she's a
high school student
in california and she has set up this
organization
for other teens to get teen
adolescent immunization rates up uh
in various communities and and obviously
we know that uh that age group is a
as an area of focus for unicef her
question is um that you know what role
um could the independence of young
people play in increasing
vaccination uptake and so some of my
work has been sort of consent
uh an ascent of teens versus parents
when these choices
diverge and and for certain vaccines
um there is that situation when teens
want it
uh and parents don't um and sometimes
vice versa
so what any thoughts on that and i know
that um
autonomy is is a major factor in terms
of working with
communities but what happens are there
aid specific cutoffs uh where
after which even if you are a teen
you're more empowered to make decisions
et cetera so any any thoughts on that
dynamic
so um i think that the best
uh way to arm a campaign is something
that you said earlier assad you said
good evidence so marshall the facts
for what you know of about the
immunization campaigns for let's say
smallpox measles polio
and then share those facts become a
trusted
resource misinformation is very
difficult in
our world but if we can help guide
our sister and brother adolescence
to the trusted information
sources they will read and learn
for themselves and it will make a
difference
but sad if i may say um it sounds like
this uh young lady would be very good to
give
us advice for what she thinks would work
i've noticed that our sms
world is very affected if it is
by someone that they know so whether it
is
a an age mate
that they do not know or it's an age
mate who maybe is a celebrity
uh millie bobby brown and i have done a
couple of
um events together but you know someone
that you
trust that you would listen to that you
think knows your conditions and
wants to pitch in i think that's going
to be very important and then
son if i could just say about the future
i think that we have been working in an
old model
in which we thought that we adults would
come up with lots of solutions and that
we
would train and pass it on to the
younger generations
but that's not true now the young people
want to be part of it
so they want to roll up their sleeves
and discover and find solutions just
right alongside us and i think we
all have to now reorient our programs to
that
let them be equal partners in finding
the solutions
so i'm ready to hear from our
um activists on vaccinations to see what
we can do to help and let's start some
campaigns that will really work
uh if they work for the young maybe we
can convince some of the older kids to
also follow suit
very nice linda
you put yourself on mute yeah um so
this i think is a perfect follow-up for
what you've just said executive director
for
um many of the participants who are
attending today just like many of the
young people you've talked about
either are already looking for ways to
engage or will be moved to
action based on what we've talked about
today and do you have any specific
suggestions or even general suggestions
about how people can contribute locally
and globally to improving children's
health
either through direct engagement
targeted advocacy or by supporting
different organizations that are working
in the field
so then we talked about this uh earlier
and you said something that is just
right
which is begin start take the first step
so just start small start anywhere it
doesn't matter
where it can be a local food bank
it could be in a local hospital or
clinic
and it doesn't matter where you are you
can
telework to help or you can in person
help and then if you are so inclined
keep going in your studies be broad in
your studies
you never know what you're going to need
in life
so try to learn as much as you can
don't specialize too early because your
world is going to be even more diverse
than the world that linda and sad and i
have lived in
so learn everything you can and then
just come out here into the field
and join us we need you
we would love to see you and um
it's a big world that has a lot of needs
right now
so we need all of you every single one
of you to come out here and help us
yeah um one thing and if i may
take the liberty to ask you to put your
former usaid administrator hat on
this is a changing this is a season of
change and
i look outside my window there are a ton
of leaves out there
and it's a moment of transition for the
us
in more than one way not just the
weather but um
otherwise so that's a irrespective of
what kind of administrative political
change is happening
these moments are are a good time to
reflect
where u.s institutions should go
especially
external facing institutions like usaid
any thoughts on
how does going forward um
usaid engage with the world anything you
would do
different you know not based on what's
happening now etc
but forward-looking what would be your
thoughts
on um you know usaid as the kids say a
5.0
the new version of usaid
um usaid is an extraordinary institution
with a storied past
and they will have a storage future
so the first would be to resource it
usaid and its expertise lie
in its people and in their memories and
in their experiences
so one needs to hire train
mentor get them out there in the field
and they will be brilliant but for that
you need resourcing so number one is
resources number two is we have some
extraordinary legacies i mean what
happened with hiv aids and pepfar
is a story of health
that everyone is proud of polio we are
so close i mean we are we are really
close
we could get this done in the next few
years and if we could rid
this world of polio it would be a great
achievement
so focus on a few things that
would change the world and
that is always important whether the
institution is usaid or whether
it is unicef but usaid carries the flag
of america and thus american
institutions
corporations and foundations have a
chance to showcase many of their
innovations their digital
uh creations that will change
our world covid means that every country
stops and re-looks at its budget
and it reallocates so let us make the
case
that we reallocated for a better world
a world that includes everyone and that
there are no
children or grown-ups that are left
behind and if we can do that
as a world it will be a better place and
usaid will do its share and its part
but it's it is all hands-on dexad
and that's whether you're usaid or
unicef
or anyone else we need everybody out
there
we also need to make the case that what
happens in
the world matters to people in america
and sometimes one thinks that one's own
household or one's own community
is the limits to what you can affect
but one person can make a big difference
and
if you keep in mind the needs of the
world
around you you'll see that there is a
world out there that needs help
and that you as one person can do a lot
or you
as a big important agency like usaid
can help change the world so i'll take
the liberty of
before i thank you to ask you one last
question
um there will be you know big
catastrophic or consequential events
in general have changed the
international system
uh the second world war changed the
international system
um the the great recession or at least
the great depression
um had a an impact on the international
system
this is a an event this pandemic is an
event that impacts
everyone and you sort of function within
the un
ecosystem how does the international
system change
how does it change for the better uh
because you have had a
somewhat unique perspective that you
have led usaid obviously you talked
about usaid's role
but also you know unicef
so both a country perspective and a
global perspective
how does the um the international system
change for the better hopefully
well um there are a couple of areas that
i think
are big opportunities for us one is
we do not yet really work as one
team on the public sector side
or in the private sector side and it's
due to a lot of
different reasons but covid does remind
you
that the great research institutions are
private
the corporations that are creating the
vaccines
are private but many of the distribution
systems i mean
unicef is part of this in procuring and
distributing
could be a mix of public and private and
then when you get out into the field
into the most rural
and remote communities it tends to be
almost
completely public but couldn't we
reimagine a world in which there is a
public and private
agreement on how to collaborate in a
much better way
i think covet can teach us this i i
think this is the moment for that
and if i can bring up education again
this is our time to connect every school
in the world to the internet
if we can do that it will give a level
playing field
for every young person in the world so
they can all start at the same place
if not we will break into haves and
have-nots in a
in a really unequal way and so
this would be a great equalizer in the
world and if we could
look for those big important
once in a generation opportunities that
will be big
and then lastly assad you knew that i'd
have to say something for the young
people
but the young people want to help they
don't want to be
the beneficiaries they want to be um the
actors they want to
they want to do it themselves so as
we're doing our planning
couldn't we have some young people on
every commission
in every forum of advising us we
started something called generation
unlimited and they're young people on
the board they're young people advising
us
we have young volunteers we have two
million right now we're
heading to 20 million i mean young
people have to be included in this we're
all in this together and i think we will
come out of covid
uh and this time empowering young people
in a new
and different way so public private
and uh young people and collaboration
so that's that's a good segment what i
was going to say that
um you know that's there are certain
good things about zoom that you don't
have to
sort of drive up i-95 to come from new
york
through new haven but then there are
drawbacks as well
that we can't have real two-way
interactions
etc so hopefully when things settle down
perhaps next year or in
you know 14 18 months you would find
time to come back where you could
interact with our faculty but more
specifically our students
who are young and wise um and
uh and well why is well beyond their
ears and so and i'm sure you'll enjoy
interacting uh with them and so
hopefully you know that's
uh after you know as i said you know
i have a when this is over list and
hopefully uh
we are on your when this is over list um
uh
come back and and have another
interaction with with the broader yale
community
uh so thank you with that i want to
thank dr linda arnold
i want to thank others who helped us
coordinate and put together this event
and i especially want to
thank director for for
so not just her insightful comments but
about her
uh passionate pleas for engaging young
people
and looking forward and connecting the
world and focusing on
building if i could you know ascribe a
subtext to it to building a more
uh resilient world um
that's every time there is a catastrophe
disproportionately in tax
impacts the weakest and the youngest
amongst us so so thanks for
for taking time to do this and thank you
everyone
for signing in to for logging in and
being a part of this event
thanks